as soon as 50 caliber round hits water
typically ricochets so it's highly
unlikely that that would uh penetrate
any kind of steel hull my name is
admiral jamie fogo and i served in the
navy for almost 40 years when i retired
i took over as dean of the center for
maritime strategy of the navy league
here in washington d.c
today we're going to be looking at
warship scenes from movies and judging
how realistic they are
king kong covers his ears
not unexpectedly you know hearing
protection and hearing conservation is a
big deal in the united states navy and
if you're a gunners mate or anybody
that's been on a ship firing a small
caliber weapon to a five-inch gun
it's loud so
no doubt the only damage we did to king
kong was probably rupture his eardrums
now a u.s aircraft carrier displaces
90 000 tons according to google
king kong weighs 50 000 tons now that's
a heck of a lot of weight half the way
to the carrier dropping on its deck but
we make our aircraft carriers to be
battle ready and battle hardened so my
money's on the carrier as far as king
kong and his 50 000 times landing and
not breaking through that deck
it's not part of our tactical training
in the navy to fight
either one of those two creatures a lot
of weapons used i see uh deck guns
i see anti-submarine rockets
uh more or less realistic now when they
launch something called a hedgehog from
the starboard side of one of the ships
we don't have those anymore but some of
our allies and partners do in europe
this is a weapon that's typically used
against submarines we have a more
sophisticated and modern method it's an
anti-submarine rocket so typically a
mark 54 lightweight torpedo it's
launched into the air when it hits the
water it separates and that torpedo
behaves then just like a torpedo and the
reason you do that is to go after a
submarine
not necessarily to go after godzilla
godzilla grabs one of the ships and
rolls it over that's pretty hard to do
when you're talking about
tens of thousands of tons of
displacement and a hole form that is
designed to take bad weather now
for an aircraft carrier that displaces
90 000 tons highly unlikely for realism
uh pretty fictional here one out of ten
cradle lowered
all right now ram the projectile easy
when you ram that powder you ram it easy
real easy
this is one of the most accurate movies
on how you load a 16-inch projectile
into a
inch barrel that projectile weighs 2 000
pounds so you're essentially
loading a volkswagen beetle into the
breach of that gun and firing it at the
enemy and you notice that the projectile
it's followed by these powder charges
this was a very accurate representation
of how you load that gun there are spark
proof tools and everybody is very
careful because you know that powder is
obviously explosive and volatile and any
mistake or any spark or any flame could
set it off and blow up that turret 204
degrees callaway
[Music]
204 degrees zero four degrees this
very shiny brass device that's a gun
sight and that's to allow the gun
captain uh to take a look out and see
the direction that he's firing in that's
the way uh that we used to do it before
we had these very sophisticated fire
control radars and gun directors that
are on top of the turrets today i fire
in a hole
[Music]
i i got a chuckle out of the fact that
tommy lee jones runs toward the 16-inch
gun turret just before it's fired we had
on the battleship's procedures to
prevent sailors from being topside in
proximity to those turrets when they
fire the guns because the overpressure
the blast blew them back you know uh a
dozen or so feet and uh that's probably
fairly accurate even today with uh our
missile systems if you're launching uh
from the four deck of a destroyer
nobody's up there when you're launching
because uh there's gonna be a lot of
flash to bang as the weapon comes out of
the tube you don't want anybody to get
hurt i'd give it a 7 out of 10.
[Music]
battleship
happens to be uh one of my favorite
movies these are world war ii era ships
they're not part of the active fleet
anymore but these ships are made to
fight and when you're on one of those
battleships and you have a belt of armor
around you 12 to 17 inches thick
and 50 000 tons of steel uh to protect
you uh that's pretty reassuring
the
officer of the deck on the bridge
uses uh the anchor on the battleship to
avoid getting hit
by some of the aliens weapons uh frankly
that's pretty hokey the amount of chain
on a battleship or an aircraft carrier
uh connected to the anchor
is uh is pretty long you know it's
probably at least a thousand feet but we
don't use anchors uh for that reason uh
we use anchors to moor the ship in port
and this is in the pacific ocean which
is really deep
one thing that the viewers might not
notice
is it's so powerful that the ship
actually moves sideways several yards
when you fire a broadside it can move
significantly and you have to do a
course correction there i'd probably
give it a two i think hollywood took a
little poetic license on the anchor in
this case
this clip is tough to watch you know
probably the greatest fear that any
sailor has
is being stuck in a compartment filling
with water and being unable to get out
the ship is rolling over
ordinances exploding on board and
if you get out that's great but then
you're going to jump into the
freezing waters of the atlantic and
you're still wearing your boots and your
kit which is if you're not a good
swimmer it's pretty hard not to sink
one of the enemies
against
their escape route are these watertight
doors the watertight doors are heavy and
they're created
to contain the water that might be
leaking into a compartment
or
if there was some kind of a catastrophic
explosion the reason that they're heavy
is uh to contain that blast overpressure
in the compartment
now most doors on ships or submarines
have two kinds of latching mechanisms
there's something called a latch or a
dog we call it a dog and you know when
you're in
normal steaming
you just push the door shut and it
latches the same way a screen door does
in the event that you're at a heightened
readiness condition you will crank that
wheel to lock that door and the only way
to get it open is to open it
counterclockwise so you can imagine
you're at an awkward angle your hands
are slippery because there might be oil
in the compartment there's water in the
compartment and you're panicking uh you
know it's a life and death situation
you're trying to get out i think the
realism factor here is a 10 out of 10.
[Music]
greyhound is an absolutely phenomenal
movie it tells uh and depicts with great
historical accuracy the germans are
depicted
in the movie as deploying the wolf pack
tactics and you know you see two
torpedoes coming from different
directions you know that's more than one
submarine firing and these tactics were
extremely effective
so what you see on the bridge of the
ship is an attack on the destroyer you
know i think that was very realistic you
see the wake of the torpedo uh coming
towards you the propellers do something
we call cavitate they create bubbles as
they're going through the water and that
creates a trail behind the torpedo and
so a sharp lookout can pick that up
early and it gives the commanding
officer
an advantage to conduct those uh drastic
evasive maneuvers if it was nighttime a
lot of times it's even easier to see the
torpedo because of the phosphorescence
in the water it kind of glows as it's
coming at you a lot of these torpedoes
were electric powered they had batteries
and electric motors in them and they
would go towards the target nowadays we
have torpedoes that are propelled by
fuel and have a very long range
and so it was a different game back then
but in this case
absolutely accurate
as far as the maneuverability is
concerned of that destroyer you have to
keep in mind this is not a battleship
that displaces
50 000 tons these are
lighter ships nowadays
heavy destroyer united states navy's
about 7 800 8 000 tons the propulsion
systems on these destroyers the engines
and the propellers and the rudders are
made for speed and maneuverability
particularly because in the second
battle of the atlantic they were not
only going after surface ships they were
going after submarines and that means
you've got to be able to turn on a dime
the rounds that actually hit the water
or penetrate the water whether or not
they actually do any damage it depends
as soon as you know a 50 caliber round
hits water typically ricochets if it
does go beneath the water line you lose
velocity very quickly so it's highly
unlikely that that would penetrate any
kind of steel hall but again you never
know
so he has to surface because water's
coming in and then while he's on the
surface they finish him off in
pretty much of a brutal manner but you
see what looks like anti-aircraft guns
that are lowered to the deck plate level
as this projectile went in and it blew
up uh it may have caused secondary
explosions first there's an initial boom
and then a massive boom there's so much
oil and fuel
and weapons on board that submarine that
you know once it took that initial
penetration of the hall and those shape
charges went in and exploded this movie
gets absolutely top marks for me as far
as realism 10 out of 10.
are we absolutely sure of our position
yes sir an exact satellite fix
it's uh her majesty ship devonshire
uh that thinks she is operating in
international waters the bad guys have
somehow interfered with the navigation
system
of that ship and she's actually
operating
one mile
inside chinese territorial waters
devonshire doesn't know that now that's
not
unrealistic in digital warfare today we
just had a situation
in the black sea where somebody
spoofed the
automatic information system of a couple
of nato warships and depicted them off
the coast of sevastopol in the crimea
where there's a russian naval base
that's dangerous activity this scenario
is
is fairly realistic english is the
international language uh for
communication in airspace
or c-space but many times
somebody on the bridge of a ship
may not speak english so we have other
methods for communication we have
flashing lights we have signal flags and
we have agreements to avoid
mistakes
the ship has been overflowed by two
chinese men we believe they have hostile
intent
the commanding officer directs uh a
general alarm so that is a a call to
action stations battle stations there's
also a series of red lights that go off
uh typically on a surface ship at night
you're in a darkened ship status so
there's a very low light and
compartments
there are
you know key points throughout the the
passageways that are lit but not
necessarily red lights so there's a
little bit of
hollywood poetic license here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
the unrealistic part of the scenario is
this thing that looks like a drill
penetrating the hall of a warship like
that will not sink the warship now in
this case the bad guys figured out that
by boring through the hall at a weak
point and going in along the length or
along the keel of the ship to go through
several compartments and by that time
hms devonshire was overwhelmed with
displacement of water and it sunk so as
far as realism a one out of ten
sir i'm picking up mobile bandwidth low
latency transmissions could be a uav
data link you know the last ship is a
show that i'm very familiar with in the
clip they talk about a uav it stands for
unmanned aerial vehicle so it's a
intelligent surveillance and
reconnaissance tool in the last decade
we've seen uavs evolve from just being a
sensor that takes a video or picture and
sends it back to the mothership
to uavs with real weapons on board
enable spy radar but sir if the russians
pick it up they'll track our bearing got
30 seconds and we shut it down sir i
gave an order the spy radar that is part
of the aegis
weapon system or radar system on the
ship and the radar
that is looking out
on the horizon over the horizon in the
air and on land you know for uh a
hundred plus miles is the spy one radar
that's the best radar in the world and
it gives us uh essentially
you know 100 situational awareness i had
four of these destroyers at my disposal
when i served in europe and uh they were
absolutely terrific there's really uh
two areas of the ship that
are areas where the ship is controlled
one is the bridge so that's where you
drive the ship that's where you control
speed and rudder and course and
direction the the real heart of the ship
for fighting is in the combat
information center you see the sailors
taking direction
from their skipper and carrying out that
direction
effectively what i like about the series
and what i like about the scene is
it's the calm professionalism that you
would expect i give it high marks i give
it uh for realism and professionalism i
give it a nine out of ten
general quarters
sound general quarters all engines are
head full bye eyes
[Music]
you know you hear uh whistle signals
from the bridge in this particular case
these guys are at battle stations they
want to get people's attention and in
the surface navy today tradition
uh
will have it that when somebody wants to
address the crew over the general
announcing system oftentimes the bosun
will blow his pipe to get the attention
of everybody
stand by to roll depth charges
it speeds towards the submarine the
submarine submerges it drops a series of
depth charges those depth charges are in
canisters they look like 50 gallon drums
on the stern of the ship and they were
actually rolled off the ship after a
gunner's mate
set the charge
to explode and set the depth that it
would explode at you had to estimate at
how deep you thought that submarine had
dove after she went from the surface
down to try to evade you and it was a
bit of a guessing game but
you know there are limits to how deep
the submarine can go for historical
accuracy
10 out of 10. thanks for watching and if
you enjoyed the video click on the link
above